[Musique]
il y a quelques jours une mère et sa
fille ont vécu une scène dramatique à la
gare Montparnasse elles ont assisté
toutes les deux impuissante à la mort de
leur animal
alors qu'elle s'apprête à partir à
Bordeaux leur chat Neco s'échappe et
court se réfugier sous un train elle
demande à leur aux agents d'intervenir
mais rien n'y fait le train démarre pour
éviter d'être en retard et l'animal se
retrouve coupé en deux sous leurs yeux
une scène qui a choqué la jeune
propriétaire
ils ont qu'un chat et que ce n'était pas
leur problème mais qui a aussi émulé
français scandalisé la Fondation
Brigitte Bardot on s'en remet à eux et
on ne fait rien c'est c'est assez
scandaleux
[Musique]
alors je vais vous raconter la faire le
2 janvier dernier donc je reviens avec
sa fille de 15 ans méléna s'apprête à
quitter Paris en direction de Bordeaux
elle transporte leur chat déco voilà
dans une caisse les deux femmes ont payé
un billet de train en plus pour pouvoir
voyager avec leur chat ça c'est
important de payer un billet de train en
plus voilà donc c'est comme un passage
un passage
cependant le chat s'échappe de sa caisse
par peur il décide de se réfugier sous
un train et de propriétaires préviennent
directement le personnel de la gare mais
les agents leur répondent que ce n'est
pas leur problème et qu'ils auraient dû
le garder en laisse ils ajoutent que ce
n'est qu'un chat
la SNCF interdit formellement aux deux
femmes d'aller tenter de sauver l'animal
elle-même pour des raisons de sécurité
après 20 minutes de négociation le train
démarre comme prévu les deux maîtresses
voient leurs chats se faire couper en
deux
c'est après le drame la SNCF propose aux
deux femmes de récupérer le corps du
chat
il est impossible de récupérer chat
alors qu'il était encore vivant mais il
est possible d'aller le récupérer le
corps maintenant qu'il est mort et voilà
donc c'est
les deux maîtresses de monde justice la
SNCF a été contacté par BFM TV et a dit
regretter ce triste incident et se
préoccupe de la condition animale ce
sont justifiées les formats non
interdits de descendre sur les voies ce
qui mettra en danger la vie de deux
voyageuses ou de nos agents les
installations ferroviaires sont
dangereuses dès lors que l'on est plus
sur un quai et la sécurité et la
première de nos priorités intrains
stationnées dans une gare est en effet
toujours alimenté en électricité et les
risques d'électrocution sont réels ce
que dit la loi
depuis 2015 l'animal est reconnu dans sa
nature d'être vivant et sensible dans le
Code civil vivant et sensible les
animaux sont des êtres vivants doués de
sensibilité sous réserves des lois qui
les protègent les animaux sont soumis au
régime des biens comme tout le monde les
deux maîtresses ont reçu énormément de
soutien sur les réseaux sociaux vous
est-ce que vous pensez que la SNCF
doit-elle être condamnée est-ce qu'ils
auraient dû sauver ce chat oui pour vous
mais oui elle doit être condamnée
puisque ça même et puis de toute façon
l'excuse elle est pas bonne du tout pour
moi ils sont en train de t'expliquer
qu'on peut pas descendre sur les voix
mais attends on est quand même au
courant mais à cette heure-ci le chat il
était encore en vie et sous un train on
n'a pas demandé à ce que on est sur les
voiles récupérées on a demandé un petit
peu de temps et un petit peu de retard
du train pour l'appeler pour la pâtée
avec de la nourriture pour faire quelque
chose pour que le chat revienne en plus
la maîtresse elle l'expliquait le chien
il levait la tête quand on lui quand on
lui parlait donc c'est à dire que le
chat il était apeuré mais il aurait pu
très bien rejoindre sa maîtresse à un
moment donné donc moi je trouve ça
révoltant parce que il y a tout le temps
des retards il y a tout le temps des
annulations il y a tout le temps des
problèmes maintenant je prends tout le
temps je sais très bien comment ça se
passe donc arrêtez de vous moquer de
nous c'est il y a un chat sur les sur
les rails vous pouvez très bien avoir
encore un retard et ce sera pour une
fois un retard justifié
ce que dit ma camarade et qui t'a quitte
parce que j'ai entendu oui mais c'est de
la faute de la des propriétaires ils
avaient qu'à surveiller leur chat et ben
moi je préfère à ce moment-là qu'on
attend de qu'on mette le temps qu'il
faut qu'on évidemment qu'on mette des
gens en retard ça j'en suis navré mais
que par ailleurs peut-être on met une
amende pour défaut de surveillance
pourquoi pas aux propriétaires je suis
d'accord voilà et on aurait et tout le
monde aurait été content et on aurait
pas tué un animal qui je le rappelle
selon la loi est un être vivant et
sensible donc à partir du moment où on
décide par la loi que s'il s'agit d'un
être vivant et sensible on va pas
sciemment prendre le risque de tuer un
être vivant et sensible Géraldine toi tu
penses que évidemment que c'est un fait
divers tragique et que vraiment ça fait
beaucoup de peine et que ça doit être
horrible et que j'imagine que la maman
et la fille sont complètement
traumatisées une fois qu'on a dit ça je
trouve que vraiment tomber sur le dos de
la SNCF et c'est pour agents qui ont
fait comme ils ont pu ils ont quand même
parlementer pendant 20 minutes qu'est-ce
qu'il aurait fallu faire en fait
condamner qui et à quoi il y a qu'est-ce
qu'on aurait si on bougeait le train on
condamné ils imaginaient rouge en train
le chat par réflexe il aurait bougé il
se sera enfui bon ben c'est pas ce qui
s'est passé il est resté à morph et il a
pas bougé comment on peut faire s'il y a
des gens par exemple
âgés dans le train qui sont malades qui
ont un traitement qui peuvent pas le
prendre non
il va avoir des retards
à un moment donné il y a aussi il y a
aussi d'autres trains il y a aussi
d'autres responsabilités les pauses
agents de la SNCF ils ont fait ce qu'ils
ont pu c'était la fin des vacances
scolaires c'était super chaud ils ont
répondu cette région par définition que
tu te dis je demande juste qu'on fasse
une enquête et qu'on on écoute quand
même les agents parce que là on a qu'une
version des faits on sait pas exactement
ce qui s'est passé et oui quand on a des
animaux on est responsable de ces
animaux et on les surveille donc
oui parce que l'histoire elle est
évidemment tragique et bouleversante je
comprends c'est peut-être deux personnes
elles sont bouleversées et c'est une
horreur en revanche je rappelle une fois
de plus que les lignes sont électrifiées
donc on peut pas descendre tout le monde
sait qu'on ne peut pas descendre sur les
voies donc malheureusement le chat il
est resté là aucun agent n'a le droit de
descendre sur les voies comme le public
donc il faut aussi être logique donc
condamner peut-être le conducteur qui
n'a pas fait d'effort je sais même pas
sûr puisqu'il a pas le droit de
descendre façon de sa cabine ni
descendre sur les voies c'est on le sait
bon j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure j'étais
cheminot c'est électrifié il y a même eu
des gens déjà é moi j'ai vu des gens qui
ont pris des décharges en descendance
pour des raisons
non mais là justement tu tu fais en
sorte de tous sécuriser et tu as le même
retard mais pour une vraie raison qui
est de nature animale bien sûr c'est
incroyable ce manque d'humanité de
Géraldine Bernard quand même et et Cyril
vous avez prononcé la phrase ce n'est
qu'un chat c'est ce qu'a dit la SNCF ce
n'est qu'un chat mais au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est impossible
d'entendre ça et moi je suis et moi je
suis du côté de 30 millions d'amis qui a
porté plainte et dans la plainte de 30
millions d'amis c'est très intéressant
parce qu'il y a des mots qui sont
vraiment précieux alors dites-nous
sciemment délibérément en conscience la
SNCF a écrasé un chat pourquoi ils font
ça 30 Millions d'Amis parce que
aujourd'hui il y a une loi qui fait que
si vous commettez un acte de cruauté en
conscience sciemment délibérément
figurez-vous que ça peut aller jusqu'à 5
ans de prison et 75000 euros d'amende
mais la SNCF et la SNCF soutenu par
Géraldine et Bernard va plaider Benjamin
Castaldi mais alors ben
Benjamin horloge m'a dit des choses je
lui ai dit si tu ne les répètes pas je
le dirai pour toi et franchement Cyril
vous allez découvrir Castaldi sur son
vrai jour vas-y connais déjà extrêmement
pour ce chat mais effectivement on
va pas on va on va pas retarder un chien
pour un train pour un chat je suis
désolé je suis désolé il faut arrêter
des conneries après l'argument
qu'est-ce qu'on doit pas faire on doit
pas faire quoi on doit pas rendez-vous
on avance sur le chat
coupe le chat en deux
moi si j'ai un rendez-vous ce qu'il a
dit si j'ai un rendez-vous 20 minutes
après qu'on ne retape pas mon train
qu'on coupe le chat en deux il a dit ça
je suis désolé pour le chat il fallait
pas qu'il descend après non si la dame
était descendue
c'est horrible c'est un chat et c'est
tout le monde c'est du retard
s voilà
mais moi je pense que la SNCF malgré
tout
on rigole mais c'est extrêmement grave
au-delà de cette affaire ça montre bien
la manière dont toute une partie de la
société considère les animaux
c'est-à-dire comme des objets en fait
les gens les gens qui ont décidé
sciemment de ne pas sauver ce chat ils
se sont dit ce sont des objets et pardon
mais c'était un être humain on aurait
fait quelque chose pourquoi on ne fait
rien parce que c'est un animal ce sont
des
êtres dotés d'une sensibilité qui nous
aime qu'on aime qui souffre donc pour
moi il faut une sanction exemplaire
qu'on arrête de considérer les animaux
comme des objets et Castaldi beaucoup de
gens sont comme des fous euh sur Twitter
vous insulte non mais je vous le dis
parce que ils disent si ça avait été
votre chien il fait quoi voilà mon chien
je dois être tenues
[Applaudissements]
évidemment la relation entre le maître
et l'animal était épouvantable et c'est
traumatisant pour la fille répond à la
question mais moi je vous dis par
rapport aux
usagers de la SNCF les gens qui sont pas
c'est pas leur chat c'est pas leur chien
au milieu des rails j'aurais tout fait
pour le
sauverai
de la SNCF et la SNCF est pas
responsable qui a un chat mais si ils
sont pas responsables qui a un chien ou
un chien
mais non j'aurais pas accepter mon
message
tu t'en fous de ce pauvre chat qui
mérite tu l'aurais coupé
alors il y a il y a même un tweet il y a
la même un tweet de la mère Michel qui
se dit très déçu
arrêtez je comprends je comprends je
comprends je comprends l'effroi
effectivement de des personnes parce que
c'est leur animal mais les gens qui sont
dans le PGV ils ont formé pour un chat
je me mets à la place des autres c'est
pas pareil mais c'est pas pareil bah
voilà
Gilles Verdez propose quoi de la prison
pour ses premières lettres
il y a plein de 30 millions d'amis au
bout et que la SNCF sera condamné comme
personne morale j'espère qu'il y aura de
la prison pour avoir tué
très clair moi je vous le dis très
clairement j'espère que la la la le gars
qui va arriver dans la cellule
[Rires]
non j'ai tué un chat et toi
tu imagines tu te mets à leur place tu
vois le train passé c'est trop mignon
c'est un chat qui appartient à quelqu'un
à partir du moment que c'est signalé
qu'on te dit il y a mon chat et que
l'argent SNCF il le sait et que l'autre
il le sait tu passes une annonce dans le
train pour dire on aura du retard il y a
un chat sur les voies une question si
c'est un un enfant de 2-3 ans on descend
pas chercher l'enfant on fait partir le
train et on coupe l'enfant en deux bah
non mais on peut pas descendre sur les
voies soi-disant la réponse de la SNCF
c'est électrifiée on peut pas descendre
il y a un petit garçon marche de 3 ans
tombe sur les quais bah qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'il peut pas tomber non mais tu
fais si c'est un enfant toi qu'est-ce
que tu fais tu descends bien chercher
l'enfant électrocuté et là c'est par
accident il était dans une caisse quand
tu dis je le tiens en laisse il était
dans une caisse il s'est sauvé ça arrive
à partir du moment où tu as l'info faut
pas dire à la SNCF demain il y a un
autre chat allez-y il y a jurisprudence
on peut rouler sur les chats maintenant
suffisamment important pour qu'on paye
un billet mais il est pas suffisamment
important
[Applaudissements]
ça fait des années
c'est ça c'est ce cynisme et de la SNCF
et que vous reprenez tranquillement
c'est-à-dire quand même Géraldine tu as
dit bah oui mais elle avait capable de
laisser tomber donc on prend l'exemple
de l'enfance
maximum
aurait été d'accord pour attendre alors
là si j'avais demandé au voyageur
il y a qu'un mec
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
le comble de l'hypocrisie de la SNCF
c'est que dans un premier temps pour
calmer l'affaire et la proposer un
billet gratuit à la dame et à ça
ils n'ont pas du tout pris la mesure du
drame qui s'est joué sur les rats
et d'ailleurs la dame et leur fille le
prend signaler qui a eu un contrôleur
qui a été extrêmement gentil avec elle
et compréhensif bien sûr une profession
moi sur la SNCF je vous ai dit
non rajoutez pas ok couper les chats en
deux à dessin on en rajoutez pas et
demain tu seras connu comme le gars qui
coupe les champs de d'ailleurs j'ai une
question vous êtes vous êtes en ville et
voilà vous avez votre voiture à 50 à
l'heure ok malheureusement il y a un
chien ou un chat qui traverse quel est
le bon comportement à boire
d'accord et après tu cherches pas pour
si tu arrives pas à payer tu fais quoi
mais je comprends pas votre situation
on a un choix à faire effectivement tout
le monde vous dira tout le monde vous
dira voilà la dernière fois
j'étais sur le périph il y a un tigre
qui est passé
le tigre ça fait du cirque plus de
risques un exemple tu as plus de risques
à mettre en dents à mettre en danger les
autres en essayant d'éviter mon freinant
qui est un peu de chance
[Applaudissements]
sur le chien
voilà touche touche à 141%
moi je suis quand même d'accord
et lui déjà la dernière fois il
préférait qu'on sort un chien plutôt
qu'un enfant non mon chien bah oui mais
oui mais alors tu préfères alors je peux
te poser une question écraser un enfant
je veux ta réponse
tu dois sauver dans une maison ton chien
ou Castaldi ok alors franchement
franchement ton chien sans hésiter mon
chien bien sûr n'hésite pas une seconde
bien sûr mais même le chien d'un autre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]